Тут, у Сопоті, розташований державний
збройний завод - ВМЗ.
Підійти ближче не можна, зйомка суворо заборонена.
Гірка правда у тому, що болгарська зброя постачається
джихадистам у зони бойових дій по всьому світі.
Aлеппо, грудень 2016-го.
Гайтанджиєва працювала там як воєнна репортерка.
Разом з сирійським оператором вони знімали
облогу міста урядовими військами
та бойовиками "Хезболли".
Східна частина Алеппо тоді  була підконтрольною
близькому до "Аль-Каїди" "Фронту ан-Нусра".
Після захоплення одного з районів міста місцеві
мешканці відвели журналістку до підвалу.
Там вона побачила, серед іншого, ракети "Град",
виготовлені у болгарському Сопоті.
Для мене було цілковитим шоком побачити
болгарські лейбли на цій смертоносній зброї.
Вона зберігалась у сховищі "Аль-Нусри", близької до "Аль-Каїди".
Знахідка журналістки особливої уваги не привернула.
І цього року вона продовжила розслідування.
Дехто надав їй засекречені документи з
азербайджанського посольства в Софії.
Ці документи показують, що азербайджанська
держкомпанія Silk Way Airlines надала
дипломатичний літак для доправлення зброї.
Згодом цю зброю виявили у Сирії.
Гайтанджиєва переконана, що азербайджанський
літак зі зброєю завантажився у Болгарії.
А звідти вирушив до Саудівської Аравії і Туречини.
В обхід болгарської митниці.
Але з дозволу міністерства закордонних справ.
Журналістка розповіла про 350 випадків експорту зброї.
Яку на вантажівках потім доправляли до Сирії,
безпосередньо терористам.
Мою статтю опубліковали в цій газеті.
Згодом мене допитала Агенція національної безпеки Болгарії.
І лише за кілька годин після допиту
"Труд дейлі" вирішив припинити мій контракт.
Відтоді журналістка безробітна.
При цьому її репутацію як чесної журналістки
намагаються заплямувати.
Тихомир Безлов із Центру вивчення демократії у Софії припускає,
що Гайтанджиєву навмисно повели до зброї,
ймовірно для того, аби заблокувати членство Болгарії у НАТО.
Це була спроба Росії залучити болгарську
журналістку з її знімальною групою,
навмисне привести її туди і показати.
Це ще питання, що нам там, в Алеппо, показали.
Натомість опозиційний політик та експерт з Близького Сходу
Славчо Вельков бачить ситуацію інакше.
Розслідування Гайтанджиєвої, на його думку, варте довіри.
Якщо ми беремо до уваги те, що "Аль-Нусра" була
найважливішою джихадистською силою у східному Алеппо,
то не дивно, що у них знайшли болгарську та іншу зброю.
Інтерес до озброєння надзвичайно великий.
І "гарячі точки" на Близькому Сході не так вже
й далеко від Болгарії.
За даними DW, у 2016 році Болгарія експортувала
зброї на мільярд євро.
На 60 відсотків більше, ніж торік.
Більша частина цієї зброї, ймовірно пішла
на Близький Схід.
Проте жодної відповіді від болгарського уряду
на запит з цього питання редакція не отримала.
Диляна Гайтанджиєва не може зрозуміти,
чому немає розслідувань після її матеріалу.
Натомість піддають критиці саму журналістку.
Я би хотіла сказати усім болгарам, які заявляють,
що я діяла на чиєсь замовлення.
Поїдьте у Сирію і побачите на власні очі болгарську
зброю у руках джихадистів в Алеппо.
Журналістка бореться за свою репутацію та проти
потужного болгарського збройного лобі.
Бореться сам-на-сам.